well i guess mars
uh oligarchy must if you don't know
means pre-practice
i don't know who's watching these films
well they're old hands or
or new people okay the ken
when karen the ken walking along and
wherever you're walking walking along
don't have the ken sticking out like
that in the back
you should about see my hand but that's
all you should be able to seal the ken
yes perhaps you can see the bottom of
the can of course
but this is rude to have it out like
that you would you would just walk like
this
so if you're on a seminar somewhere and
you're walking
here and low not up here you're not in
the defensive position
just keep it casual but keep it um
keep it straight when you're bowing
don't stick your butt out like that
just bail from the head
the lower the bowel the more respect but
uh
when you offer the ken to your partner
if you're in
practice and you only have one ken and
you offer it with the blade to you
they take it and so so let's say
you the camera you're you've got it i
take it
soon as i put my hands out i roll it
back like this i bow
and i take it to my side
precision okay from there
from the bowel
take like with the joe the little first
two fingers closed the little finger the
second finger
and the others wrap this now keeps close
to your body
and it comes out like a wave
okay like i'm lately like a wife i
remember goes off yoda
he'd say hey hey
the ocean wave and the power of the
ocean might come out
so when you head to ikkyo
hey notice i come up my center
and out i don't just put my arm up
because
they can knock it away perhaps they can
see it coming
but if it's close to your chest
and then then like a snake's tongue it's
out there
instantly so with the ken
just feeling
the same when coming back this feeling
you think of mine
now both feet and both hands both
fingers are
closed i bring it to the camera the
little finger
should be half on the ken and half off
half on the ken and half off okay
not not some sticking out or lost
completely
half on half off with the little finger
when finishing the cut
you squeeze them both like ringing out a
towel
now a lot of people have their elbows
out here if your shoulders
can go through say a gap in the let's
say a doorway they
sense you to say if you can get through
a doorway with your shoulders
so should your elbows well look at mine
they can't so you tuck them
in so if they have come out on the
downward stroke bring them in
and squeeze so as you squeeze release
hey breathe in
i try and keep mine in all the time look
here i'm seeing
i'm looking at my enemy
hey
hey okay don't let them just come out
they're not scissors you know don't keep
doing this with them
i eat
eight eight and each one is one
okay if you want to know a lot more and
do a lot more
please contribute to my patreon page
because that's where we're going to go
into full detail these are just small
snippets to
get you get you going and hopefully
improve your you're like you know
don't want to restart